What is it that you can tell me about
that goes on behind the scenes,
underground, above-ground, all around that
keeps the university running in terms of
facilities, in terms of heating, cooling,
all those kind of issues that nobody
knows about? Sure. Our facilities
department — we got over 600 employees.
They just do an outstanding job. And part
of what we do not only are custodial and
our grounds, it's our utility management
system of the entire campus. And so we
have three plants on campus. We're
producing over 36,000 tons of chilled
water that we're producing and sending
out to the buildings in the middle of
the summer when it's 115 degrees. We're
also trying to drive down costs. We have
thermal ice that we produce that helps
us go ahead and lower our overall
electrical costs. Our utility bill on
average is about $38 million
dollars. We've been able to lower that
millions and millions over the years due to
the hard work of our facilities
management utilities staff. Tell me a
little bit about how you interact with
students because you're having to keep
us all supported, but at the same time,
there are learning and teaching
opportunities. Definitely. You know, we
have several themes within our
facilities department. One of them is we
run it like a business, extremely
effective and efficient. But also, we
graduate students. 40 to 50 classes will
come through these power plants —
mechanical engineers, electrical
engineers. It's just a great
collaborative effort. Yeah, I think it
fits right in with our land-grant
mission. I mean these are all the kind of
things that we're trying to help our
students get skills and knowledge to go
out there and be competitive in this
very rapidly changing world, and data is
a big one. It takes a great team,
harnessing the big data, so we can make
real-time decisions that have positive
benefits in our operations and then as
the strategic plan continues moving
forward, it's going to give additional
opportunities to do other initiatives if
we're being extremely efficient on our
operations side of the house. What are
some of the technological or
evolutionary changes you see coming down
we need
be aware of? We have a 10-year plan
right now to take all our buildings on
campus and have the building automation
systems all computerized. And so we're
dealing with somewhat older systems. If
we can compress that to five years we're
going to see even more positive benefits
in terms of financial benefits and
operational benefits, which also then
have major benefits for the culture
inside the buildings, for the academics,
for the students, for the research. We
have 800 meters that we've installed
underground and we can go ahead and read
every one of those each morning and see
a variance analysis. You can go ahead and
look at the monitors, you can measure
what's above the variance line, and then
make the proper decisions — what needs to
be repaired in a timely fashion. This is
like running a small city. We are a small
city, and the ability to look at policies
but also the hands-on, experiential
problem-solving, these are all the things
that we hope that our students are going
to acquire as skills and knowledge for
critical thinking, collaborative teamwork,
because you've got incredible
collaborative teamwork. And I just
appreciate the the reality check of
seeing it in practice right here today.
We're not talking about something
futuristic, you're doing it every day.